الى تطورات المشهد العسكري في اوكرانيا
ونتابعه ايضا حيث اعلن الرئيس الاوكراني
ان اجتماع القياده العليا للجيش اتخذ
قرارا بمواصله الحفاظ على مدينه بخموت
وحمايتها
اجتماع لقياده الاركان واطلعنا على تقارير
من اللجنه المركزيه والاستخبارات وقاده
المناطق ان تركيزنا ينصب على
موقف قياده الاركان مجتمعه واضح وهو تعزيز
هذه الجبهه وتدمير العدو بقدر ما نستطيع
بل قلت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها
تتقدم من الجهه الشماليه الغربيه لمدينه
العسكريه الخاصه ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تحضر لهجوم المضاد في ضخمه
معنى الامريكيه مراسله الجزيره حسن
الشوبكي لنرصد معه اخر المعلومات الوارده
من حول تطورات العسكريه هنا
[موسيقى]
نعم ازدهار حسب بيان هيئه الاركان للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه الذي صدر صباح اليوم
هنالك تاكيد بان 90 هجوما قد تم تنفيذها
في عده مواقع وجبهات منها يعني مارينكا
وكذلك
يعني هجوم من الطرف الروسي باتجاه المناطق
الشماليه الغربيه لباخمت وقصف
لمنطقه شاختيار وايضا القصف ايضا كان
صاروخيا بالامس لكراماتورس لكن تقول
القوات الاوكرانيه وبيان لهيئه الاركان
انها صدت هذه الهجمات في اكثر من اتجاه
وتحديدا في باخمه قالت ان هنالك يعني
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه صمدت في مواجهه
الهجمات التي تقوم بها القوات الروسيه
وقوات باجنر وهذه هجمات لم تتمكن من
الوصول الى اهدافها بالامس وحتى صباح
اليوم الحديث عن مقتل يعني
980 حسب بيان هيئه الاركان العامه من
القوات الروسيه ومليشيار هذا على الانسان
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وايضا ان هنالك
كان غارات جويه شامله اربعين غاره جويه
واثني عشر قصفا صاروخيا بالاضافه الى يعني
احتدام المعارك ووصولها الى ما يشبه حرب
الشوارع في ضخمه هنالك محاوله مستمره
ومتواصله من الطرف الاوكراني للدفاع عن
باقي مت هنالك قرار من القياده العليا في
الدوله وكذلك في اجتماع هيئه القائد
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه الذي انتهى بالامس
وصرح بلود كان رئيس الاوكراني بانه القرار
كان واضحا بالدفاع عن باقي متعزيز كل
الامدادات اللازمه لها لكي على يعني هذه
المدينه ان لا تسقط في ايدي القوات
الروسيه ومنر ازدهار على درجه كبيره من
الاهميه يعقد اليوم اجتماع ما كان يعرف
بصيغه هذا الاجتماع لتسليح ودعم العسكري
لاوكرانيا هنالك 54 من الحلفاء يمثلون
وزراء دفاع وكان وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
قد اتصل مع يعني قبل يومين مع وزير الدفاع
الامريكي
وتم الاتفاق على توسيع الدعم العسكري في
خلال هذا الاجتماع سيكون مناقشه هذا الامر
بشكل جلي تطلب اوكرانيا مليون قذيفه من
عيار
155 مليمتر وهي من القذائف المدفعيه
الثقيله وكذلك تطلب انظمه دفاع جوي اضافه
الى طائرات وهذا ليتسنى لها القيام بهجوم
مضاد ضد القوات الروسيه على اكثر من محور
ضمن ما يعرف بمعركه الربيع
شكرا جزيلا لك